what do you do when the sun turns wrong
when light which once represented life
joy and warmth becomes a symbol of death
and destruction do you hide inside
shutter the windows keep out the light
by any means necessary do you retreat
underground where the sun's rays cannot
penetrate burrowing into the dark and
the cold do you simply give yourself to
it accepting that there is no escaping
something so vast so far reaching as
sunlight itself and allow yourself to be
lost in the end of all things we've
covered this possibility before scp-001
when day breaks or sd lock's proposal
it's difficult to know what any given
person might do in such harrowing
circumstances after all we have always
learned to love the light and fear the
darkness it turns our very understanding
of reality upside down to have that
paradigm shifted the dark becoming
safety and the light becoming death the
source of all life on earth of all
warmth transforming in an instant from
the sun as we know it to a napoleon
class scp that melts all living
organisms that cross into its gaze but
what about a being that has always
feared the light something that
prioritizes solitude and never ever
wants to be seen how might it live out
those darkened days today we're taking a
look at what happens when daybreak meets
a familiar face even if a constantly
hidden one scp-096
scp-096 or the shy guy is something of a
celebrity around here it is a humanoid
creature with long distended arms pale
skin and a jaw that can open four times
wider than an ordinary humans there is
only one thing above all else that this
entity desires for no one to see its
face when someone views its face it
flies into an uncontrollable rage and
seems to have no other option but to
destroy the person who has seen it so it
is unlikely that a creature so intent on
solitude would be in much danger from
the transformed sun in fact it might
even be a positive thing and for some
time it was with so many human beings
gone reduced to gelatinous masses with
no desire but to slither around in the
ghoulish sunlight and merge with one
another there were fewer people to
observe his face than ever he could stay
inside and know with almost complete
certainty that no one would come to
bother him no one was coming to look at
him and there were no more visitors
researchers poking and prodding that
might sneak a look at his face and so he
stayed there in the room that had served
as his containment unit before the world
turned upside down the masses of flesh
that once were humans did not concern
him as they never looked at his face all
he did was stay in his room and never go
outside the outside frightened him
terribly though he was not concerned
with the deadly sunlight or the
possibility of it melting him as it had
so many others he was much more afraid
that someone some unlikely survivor
clinging to their original life might
look at him that they might see his face
that was simply too distressing to risk
he would much rather stay alone in his
old cell weeping softly in the shadows
one day though we couldn't say how many
days after the end of things it had been
he was weeping alone in his former cell
the days blurred together spent the same
way and time had lost much of its
meaning through the echoing sound of his
sobs and the sloshing sounds of the
creatures outside a woman's voice cut
through it was faint but he could make
out what she was saying she was calling
out for help asking if anyone had any
food or fresh water the sound was
getting louder closer accompanied by the
disconcerting thump of her footsteps she
was coming down the hall as much as it
could be called a hall anymore she was
coming towards his room to disrupt his
miserable peace he heard her steps
crossed the threshold of his room and
her voice broke into a terrified scream
no doubt at the unexpected sight of a
pale naked creature weeping in the
corner of what she expected to be an
empty room startled by the first loud
sound he'd heard in a long time in a
world that had mostly been silent since
the initial outpouring of agonized
screams had faded into the soft slap of
flesh and slime on the ground he turned
around he shouldn't ordinarily he
wouldn't but he couldn't stop himself
there he saw a woman wide eyes filled
with tears face streaked with dirt a
small child next to her holding her hand
and clinging to her leg just as he saw
the woman she saw him she saw his face
anger boiled over inside of him and he
let out a scream wild primal and filled
with inhuman rage
she could not be looking at him
seeing his face he couldn't let her the
woman ran with the child in tow panicked
by the wild roar and the sight of him
standing upright before her the anger
faded as she left his sight making her
way down the hall into the stairs but
then he remembered she had seen his face
he could not let her leave it was time
to do something he never thought he'd
have to do again hunt his heightened
senses picked up the sound of muffled
footsteps coming up through the floor
below him she was downstairs just
beneath the floor where he was standing
his instincts kicked in and his body
moved almost of its own accord he lifted
his long long arms above his head and
drove his hands down into the floor it
was weakened by the ravages of the
elements and time and crumbled under his
unnatural strength he dug his claws into
the plaster tearing it apart and
cracking it into pieces he pushed his
claws in deeper and deeper until he
could feel them breaking through the
other side he pulled the floor apart
until the hole was wide enough to fit
through then dropped down to the room
below he spotted the woman's back
fleeing through the door just as he
landed she was getting away he tore
after her ripping through concrete and
steel destroying everything in his path
in a mad dash for the object of his rage
he had to catch her she could not be
allowed to leave she looked over her
shoulder at him her face a mask of pure
terror she knew just as he knew that
there was no escape in sight in his
single-minded obsession and her
desperation to escape from him neither
of them noticed that she had run so far
and so carelessly that she was now
outside the building she had crossed
from the shadows into the harsh light of
the sun the woman's eyes widened in grim
understanding of her fate he could only
watch helplessly as her body began to
succumb to the vicious rays almost
instantly she began to melt as it was
closest to the sun her head was the
first to go her nose drooped like hot
wax dripping as it went until it slumped
off her face and landed on the ground
with a sickening splash her eyes were
next popping out of their sockets and
hanging loose and limp on her cheeks and
dangling from sinewy strands she tried
in vain to stuff them back into place
but they squished in her hands like over
ripe fruit she attempted to run into the
comparative safety of the ruined
building but her feet were already
beginning to spread out onto the street
melting into a sticky red smear on the
pavement her legs crumbled beneath her
and she collapsed to the ground her face
leaving a trail of gelatinous flesh as
it landed she tried uselessly to drag
herself along the ground back into the
darkness but her arms were melting into
the dirt mixing with it into a horrible
red mud she let out a last scream of
agony but the sound turned to a thick
gurgle as her lips fused together and
her mouth melted into nothingness he
watched it all
sobbing and roaring in frustration she
was gone and he would never get the
satisfaction of ending her the infernal
son had stolen her from him now she was
nothing but a wet shadow like the rest
of the humans had become long ago he
heard the sound of a soft sob behind him
a tiny human voice he turned looking for
the source there was the little girl he
had almost forgotten about her she was
calling out for her mother and crying
and she was looking right at him right
at his face he waited for the anger to
overtake him but instead there was
nothing why wasn't he angry she was
looking at his face so why then he
realized her eyes were on him but she
did not see him she was blind she
approached the creature her arms
outstretched following the sound of his
crying she touched his hand with her own
tiny fingers so small and fragile and
asked mommy then he felt something he
had never felt before tenderness care a
desire to protect this tiny innocent
being it was the first time he had ever
felt warm he never felt anything but
sadness anger or fear overcome with his
softness he wrapped his arms around the
child and hugged her close she hugged
him back tightly and the room went quiet
as they both stopped crying from that
day on they became a family of sorts
they lived together and he took care of
her she didn't know what he looked like
and had no idea he might be something to
fear to her he was safety he was home
for the first time in his long awful
life he felt like a human instead of a
monster he would scavenge food for her
bring her fresh water lay down stolen
blankets and pillows so she would have a
soft place to rest he even found her a
ratty worn teddy bear amongst the rubble
and gave it to her as a gift she
clutched it to her chest and thanked him
and for once his tears were those of joy
in this cursed world they had found
something like happiness in one another
he knew he would protect her no matter
what then one day everything changed the
creature and the little girl were
playing in the abandoned site making up
little games together when he took a
break to look out at the window and
monitor their surroundings outside the
evil red sun waited when he turned back
the little girl was gone one of the
shadowy creatures once human was
imitating his voice to lure her away he
could hear it in the distance and her
tiny footsteps following it he chased
after her the only thing he had ever
loved and saw her just as she stepped
out into the light she screamed as one
of her arms began to melt in the light
and he knew what he had to do he grabbed
her and pulled her back inside using his
body to shield her from the horrible
rays as he wept over her his tears
stopped her body from melting any
further but his body continued to fall
apart it was too late for him he ran as
far as he could once he transformed he
did not want to end up hurting the girl
he ran until his legs melted away and he
could not run anymore he had reached the
shoreline and stared out at the ocean
unable to move anymore he screamed a
final time in agony in heartbreak in
mourning for the happiness he had
finally found and now would lose but at
least he knew as his eyes melted away
and he was nearly gone that the girl
would be safe and then he was gone and
the world was quiet now go check out
scp-096 the shy guy and
scp-001 when day breaks for more on the
shy guy and the scp-001 proposal that
turned the sun against all human life